alors ça s'est passé lundi lundi dernier
enfin lundi là tout de suite le 3 3
avril la police est appelée au 11 square
du temple à Vaux-sur-Seine pour un
différent familial et lorsqu'ils
arrivent il est 21h45 je sais que vous
aimez les horaires et c'est une lorsque
les policiers pénètrent dans le logement
il trouve une femme en sang blessée et
un peu plus loin dans le couloir
toujours de ce même logement le corps
d'un homme inanimé qui vit dans une mare
de sang
cette femme a 45 ans sont l'homme 51 ans
ils sont ex-compagnon il a déjà été
condamné en 2022 à 10 mois de prison
pour des violences conjugales et il
avait surtout interdiction de de la de
l'approcher de la voir ça faisait partie
de la décision judiciaire
on ne sait pas si
il s'était concerté pour se revoir ou
bien s'il était rentré en force ce soir
là dans l'appartement ça l'enquête va le
déterminer c'est en cours toujours
est-il qu'une dispute éclate dans la
soirée une dispute violente il se met à
tout casser dans la dans l'appartement
il brise des meubles il s'en prend
physiquement à cette jeune femme qui
pour se défendre va prendre un couteau
et lui mettre un coup de couteau dans la
cuisse elle a dû toucher l'artère
puisqu'il est décédé dans la nuit après
avoir été transporté par les pompiers
voilà en résumé ce qui s'est passé on
dit qu'ils étaient alcoolisés les deux
est alcoolisées les deux étaient
alcoolisés
ils avaient bu un petit peu d'alcool
l'homme est décédé donc dans la nuit à
l'hôpital de la Pitié-Salpêtrière c'est
la femme elle-même qui avait posé un
garrot à la victime voilà c'est c'est un
drame terrible je lui dis elle va elle
est en garde à vue actuellement elle va
s'expliquer sur le sur le geste ça
ressemble un petit peu
je vais peut-être un peu loin mais à de
la légitime défense elle était dans
danger elle a reçu des coups elle s'est
emparée d'un couteau le fait qu'elle
mette ce coup de couteau au niveau de la
cuisse c'est bien la démonstration
qu'elle ne veut pas le tuer enfin à mon
avis c'est c'est quand on veut que
quelqu'un on met un coup de couteau dans
la cuisse c'est plutôt au niveau de du
cœur ou de la gorge là elle frappe au
niveau de la cuisse langue de chance
elle a touché leur terre et ce qui a
entraîné la mort de ce monsieur et la
vraie question qui va à laquelle il va
falloir répondre c'est qu'est-ce que ce
type qui n'avait rien à faire là
qu'est-ce qu'il faisait là
c'est légitime défense on en est où là
bah oui c'est ça les enquêteurs tentent
de savoir en fait s'il s'était remis
ensemble effectivement c'est à dire
qu'il y a vu cette séparation est-ce
qu'ils se sont remis ensemble est-ce
qu'elle l'a invité et ce qu'ils ont pris
de l'alcool ensemble est-ce qu'il l'a
forcé à boire et à ce moment-là est-ce
qu'elle s'est défendue voilà il faut
savoir que si c'est de la légitime
défense effectivement elle pourrait ne
pas être condamnée sinon meurtre sur
conjoint conjoint c'est une circonstance
aggravante ça peut valoir très cher
puisqu'elle risque la perpétuité c'est
pour ça que le parquet là en ce moment
est assez prudent sur ce qui s'est passé
et voir si c'est un drame de l'alcool un
drame de la vengeance un drame d'une
femme agressée voilà il réfléchit les
enquêtes criminelle homicide volontaire
en l'état de ce que j'ai compris de ce
dossier
il faut qu'on arrive à établir
l'intention de donner la mort or je
reviens sur le coup de couteau dans la
cuisse c'est pas forcément une intention
de donner la mort donc il est possible
que ce soit requalifié en cause sur
volontaires et entraîner la mort sans
intention de la donnée et vous avez
raison Cyril tout de suite les
enquêteurs ont souligné effectivement
qu'elle a posé elle-même le garrot si
elle a appelé la police peut-être que
avec l'alcool elle ne sait pas rendu
compte et qu'après la perçu la gravité
du geste et qu'elle a voulu tenter de le
sauver voilà ça ça fera partie de
l'enquête bien évidemment ce sera des
éléments potentiellement à des charges
contre elles là actuellement elle va
l'emprison il va se passer quoi elle est
en garde à vue donc elle est pas encore
en prison
c'est là vraiment on est sur le fil du
rasoir je pense que la décision pour le
JLD le juge la liberté de la détention
va être compliqué parce que enfin ça va
dépendre de ce qu'elle raconte
évidemment mais pour moi l'intention
homicide je la sens pas vraiment très
très solide j'ai plus ce sentiment que
cette femme s'est défendue d'un ex qui
était extrêmement violent puisque pour
être condamné à 10 mois de prison pour
des violences conjugales faut quand même
quand on connaît le système judiciaire
c'était des vrais violences donc voilà
c'est une femme qui
peut-être même si elle était d'accord
pour le voir on peut on peut imaginer on
peut tout imaginer elle était d'accord
pour le voir mais elle était pas
d'accord pour qui casse tout dans la
maison et pas d'accord non plus pour qui
lui tape dessus parce qu'elle est blessé
elle est également
il n'y a pas que le mobilier qui a
souffert et là était frappé elle a reçu
des coups elle avait le visage en sang
lorsque les policiers sont à la gare qui
a éclatés et puis elle a voulu défendre
a priori et donc prison vous avez dit un
truc important c'est que elle lui a mis
un coup de couteau dans la jambe au
départ on se dit bon c'est calibre pas
elle voulait juste le le calmer au
départ et forcément la toucher
blessures volontaire et entraîne la mort
sans intention de la donner enfin moi ça
me paraît plus si c'est cette c'est ce
qui est c'est ce qui est retenu elle
risque quoi on va la peine est bien
moindre puisque missile volontaire c'est
30 ans et là je crois que c'est dix ans
oui enfin on est toujours dans les
peines maximum mais on dit jamais la
peine minimale
dans dans ce dossier qu'on connaît pas
évidemment par cœur si il s'avère parce
que je pense que c'est la question que
se pose tous les téléspectateurs que
vraiment comme on l'a vu déjà donc on
connaît l'histoire il l'a frappé à
plusieurs reprises qu'à un moment elle
en a eu marre à essayer de se défendre
et que elle a fait elle a eu elle a eu
un coup qui a été qui a été fatal mais
elle voulait pas elle avait pas
l'intention de donner la mort est-ce
qu'elle risque quand même de la prison
est-ce qu'elle peut être lâché tout de
suite parce que je vous ai tout à
l'heure on est sur le fil du rasoir ça a
vraiment dépendre de la femme
si voilà légitime défense totale
si c'est légitime défense il y a pas de
il y a plus de d'instruction et puis
d'informations d'ouverte il y a plus
d'enquête il y a plus rien ça clos enfin
ça la légitime défense une fois qu'elle
est reconnue
le dossier éclos alors pour le moment
elle n'a pas pu être entendue avec
précision au début de sa garde à vue en
raison de l'alcoolémie mais
effectivement si elle arrive ça ça peut
être ça ça peut être un facteur avant ça
peut être compliqué mais ils avaient bu
tous les deux peut-être qu'il n'était
plus lucide tous les deux et qu'elle
n'était pas lucide au moment de frapper
mais voilà à mon avis tous en
argumentaire va être de dire que elle a
agi en état de légitime défense si
vraiment elle a riposter parce qu'elle a
été attaqué à ce moment-là elle ne sera
pas condamné effectivement parce qu'on
en est du tout si elle arrive à faire
entendre ça merci Michel Marie vous avez
d'autres choses à ajouter sur cette
affaire
c'est une histoire de de violence
conjugales et que une fois de plus
je souhaite que toute la lumière soit
faite sur cette histoire de manière à
savoir si quel sera son sort si elle
doit être incarcérée parce que elle a
des torts ou bien si elle a vraiment agi
en état de légitime défense alcool ou
pas alcool l'alcool ça
ils sont tous les deux alcoolisés
qu'est-ce qui va se passer on va
attendre qu'il soit dégrisé enfin
qu'elle soit dégrisée pour l'entendre
mais l'alcool n'est ni une circonstance
aggravante ni une cirrons sans
atténuante